he's been with us from the beginning so
reg I hope you share in this new man
cave that we have in an unbelievable
basketball court that you know we would
love to see your jumper in here one day
so congratulations
Theodore and my dance I've been on the
road obviously for the playoffs and
traveling so I physically haven't seen
it on TV but I am one of your many
followers on Instagram and you guys are
doing an unbelievable story on Instagram
of the behind the scenes and things that
go on in commercial break so I actually
did get a chance to see the basketball
court with a full clock that's like
running time which is awesome the
football field
it's the murals look unbelievable and to
have my jersey yeah like above your like
your throne because you are the king you
do sit on the throne my friend I am
honored to be a part of this show I
always have been I think this is the
best in the business
in Theodore you are killing it as usual
Thank You reg I'm curious I have my own
basketball court here do most basketball
players have a basketball court at their
house yeah I remember like in the late
80s early 90s I think the only people
that really had basketball courts were
Magic Johnson and Michael Jordan but I
think it becomes a trend now the way
home bill builders and buyers and
mansions and the states are being built
now if you can get an indoor court
I know Tracy McGrady had an unbelievable
indoor court his time in Houston if you
can get it into a court that's great
most basketball players have outdoor
courts we all grew up on the outdoor
courts but the indoor courts or if you
got the cash olla that's the new trend
you
you didn't go to Shaq's place in Orlando
did you I did not that's another person
who had an unbelievable indoor facility
it was
Shaquille O'Neal yes again if you have
the cash over like Shakti Mac MJ yeah
you rich you build state-of-the-art I
believe now even though Shaq still has
is he has it's part of his because he
does a lot of you know he's a celebrity
DJ now and it's very good I my dad
so that's he built like a studio for his
D gene as well that's a part of his
basketball facility who started
weightlifting in the NBA it became a
trend one Michael Jordan continued to
get beat up by the bad boys I'm not
going to say that he was the innovator
but everyone started to lift weights
because in the 80s the whole thing of
lifting weight was gonna throw your shot
off you couldn't get too bulky and when
the bad boys were having their reign and
they were you know physically abusing
Scottie Pippen and Michael Jordan and
Michael said enough is enough
and he got in the weight room and
documented it and I think that's when
you know because everyone followed you
know the Pied Piper at the time that's
what everyone turned their interest
towards lifting weights now your power
poise and sinners always lifted weights
because they really that's one powerful
power force they said screens they
rebound it and they did all the physical
work but the point guards and shooting
guards and even small forwards lifting
weights was kind of like a taboo now
it's like mainstream everyone lives in
the weight room and rightfully so but I
started lifting weights and going to
push-ups and pull-ups and all that I was
part of the Pied Piper following MJ MJ
is doing it we all got to do it and
that's when I started Shaq was on
yesterday and we didn't agree on
something I said that I thought that
James Harden is the most versatile
scorer in modern day NBA history and I
said even more so than Michael and Kobe
but I said in fairness to them they
played in a different time certainly
Michael did and he would have
incorporated the three-point shot but I
said that
prints with James Harden is he can hit
the three the 15-footer he can dunk on
you he can take contact he can shoot a
lot of free throws and I think he's the
most versatile scorer that we've had
most dominating versatile scorer that
we've had in a long long time in check
didn't agree agree agree because he has
based his game towards the rules it's
funny because if you put James Harden in
the late 80s in the 90s in my era and
you put MJ in today's era you're
wondering who would be more successful
with their current skill level I would
have to assume it would be Michael
Jordan because we saw what Michael
Jordan did when you could hold hit
clutch take people out the air he was
still successful as great as hardens the
game is I'm not quite sure Harden would
put up these type of numbers yeah in the
90s he certainly could don't get me
wrong I still think he would be
efficient but his game is tailor-made to
the way the modern NBA is played we're
talking to Reggie Miller the
hall-of-famer Turner Sports NBA analyst
just saw this for a major in motor
neurone ski ty lue is meeting with the
Lakers today and the expectation Monty
Williams and the Lakers will talk again
who should be the next head coach of the
Lakers who makes the most sense in your
opinion there's a history with LeBron
having won a championship in Cleveland I
think the deal is there
I think Monty Williams has the
experiences with LeBron from I believe
Team USA when he was an assistant coach
look it's gonna come down to
communication and if you are both those
coaches tyloo Monty Williams I want to
know what kind of infrastructure am I'm
gonna be walking into if law palinka the
general manager is doing the
interviewing is he going to be there any
it's gonna be the one that going to lead
you know come July first you know they
all start bidding and getting these free
agents in is he going to be the guy are
they gonna be bringing in someone else
so if I'm the head coach those are the
questions I want to know first like yeah
you're interviewing me now but if I
happen to sign with you guys are you
going to be around July first who makes
the most sense
you can ask LeBron that surprises the
one who's going to make the final
decision anyways right so but why is it
I mean is this just for cosmetics that
you have Rob pálinka interviewing tyloo
but if LeBron once
tyloo is tyloo getting Miss John if Ron
wants it LeBron is gonna get it okay
that's absolutely LeBron runs things
it's no secret I mean I'm not going to
sugarcoat it yeah but you see the right
guy know just how you want it yeah I'm
assuming if he's being interviewed he
wants to get back in the league and he
wants to coach the Lakers I mean again
he plays for the Lakers you want a
championship under Phil Jackson with the
Lakers it makes sense you know for a
Laker nation to have someone that
they're familiar with and the LeBron is
familiar with if the Thunder lose
tonight not done wait to season again
you get Westbrook average to trouble
double again you had Paul George who was
in the MVP discussion for three quarters
of the year until that shoulder injury
but to me it's a wasted season and it's
a disappointing season because they are
on the better half of the draw this year
with Golden State and Houston having to
face one another in the second round I
mean it's almost like a walk to the
investor conference finals and if you go
out in the first round it's really
disappointing but again their makeup of
their team is so they can only Paul
George can shoot
our team yeah I mean in today's games
you've got to be surrounded by shooters
and they've got a great challenge they
go a top-10 Center and Stephen Adam and
you've got to top 10 players in
Westbrook and Paul George you can't get
out of the first round and in my opinion
Paul George apology on the first team
all-nba and you've got West local
problems be on the second team all-nba
and you can't get out of the first round
again the series shift to OKC and that
building is very difficult to win in and
Portland really hasn't shown me much on
the road but they're playing better all
they got to do though is you know when
their home games and they win the series
but I want to see what Portland is made
of when they go into enemy territory and
can they get a game
speaking of shooting or lack thereof Ben
Simmons dominated last night against the
Nets but you said this a couple of weeks
ago that you were planning on helping
him with his jump shot in the offseason
is that still on the schedule if he was
to reach out I'm sure I would meet him
up at a gym and give him some pointers
and techniques but what he has done
different in this series is he
understands his strengths and he's
employing if you watched the last two
ballgames
everything has been downhill for him I
think in Game one he was hesitant and he
wasn't confident things that he has
going for him he has a jump hook with
either hand and at 6:10 when he attacks
the basket
there's not a lot many defenses can do
so he's constantly attacking you playing
downhill and I think that has put the
net on their Hill so to speak and I
think the trash-talking with Dudley has
helped him you know the poster is going
up and all that I you know this is what
you expect you know come well with
Dudley saying he's limited in the
half-court that kind of feeds your ego a
little bit yeah but I don't know how to
shoot reg like this guy's playing elite
basketball he's gone against elite
competition like at some point did
somebody say you know I think you're
gonna need a jumper
we're gonna have a guy that's gonna be
MVP this year that really doesn't know
how to shoot as well right yeah okay it
can be done we're talking about Yannick
haunted the coop oh I that is one thing
you can develop and I think he will
develop at a time Jordan wasn't a great
shooter and develop into a pretty good
shooter magic didn't have a jump shot as
well he developed that so I think it
will come in time right now he is
catering and playing to his strengths
where it will be magnified is I believe
it ously they're gonna advance past me I
wouldn't say obviously but we are
assuming there you're going to get by
the Nets it will be magnified when they
go against Toronto it will be magnified
if they get by Toronto and go against
Milwaukee and or Boston because the
further you going to play off your best
attributes gets taken away and we all
know that he cannot shoot and it will be
magnified in that Toronto series because
magic wasn't a jump shooter magic kind
of said shot but magic could still
dominate without scoring a point and we
saw that in Game three
then feelings dominated without shooting
the basketball 31 points the steal the
finishes to hand off the fake hand off
in transition he dominated that game
without joelle indeed and but again I
hate to say this but it's the Brooklyn
net and that's to be expected it's the
first-round matchup that you should
dominate it's a three six and your
talent will rise now when you got to go
against Kawhi Leonard and see Occam and
those kind of guy that's where again
your ward start to kind of show
themselves Barkley said that he is
taking Portland to win the West I think
it's a favorable draw we talked about
OKC
getting to the Western finals I mean you
would assume who would be favored in
that Denver San Antonio series if it's
OKC in Portland the way Portland is
I don't discount it you know I don't see
them being golden state to get to the
NBA Finals I could certainly see them
getting to the Western Conference final
yeah that's interesting
even with their big man out and got
Oklahoma City on the ropes right now do
you when when when's your next playoff
basketball game we have game for
Brooklyn Sixers and I will say this if
I'm silly I I don't play and beat again
tomorrow because Game five is not until
I believe Tuesday so I would roll the
dice is you've already reclaimed home
court advantage to by appearances family
shooting touch 29 points you call JJ
Redick 26 points Jimmy Butler a great
all-around game I think you could
probably get away with not playing and
beat again and now you have another
three or three days where he can rest
that knee before Game five and then even
then it is questionable I think you can
beat the net without Joel embiid but
going forward you're not going to be
Toronto without indeed so the health of
him is much more important than him
trying to come back in this series reg
safe travels if you get a chance you
want to tune in during the commercial
break the live look and you'll see some
sharp shooters here on the basketball
floor I'll go out and put on a clinic
[Laughter]
love and knock down knockdown shooter I
forgot it big 11 I apologize you write
you do you are a flame thrower my
friends yeah 12 to 16 feet with nobody
on him and he does not miss Thank You
reg as always and thank you for your
support throughout the years you know I
appreciate it again congratulations well
deserved my friend it's Reggie Aloysius
Miller jr. the third for more Dan
Patrick show tune in to audience Channel
239 on DirecTV stream for free on BR
live or download the Dan Patrick show
app